hello marvel fans we're here with
benedict cumberbatch who plays doctor
strange you have had quite the busy life
my friend yeah what is it like to dive
into the marvel multiverse uh
marble is a fun place to be right now as
dr strange that's all i will say and
yeah you know he he brings something
very interesting to this film
but most of all having worked with tom
not just on this but on a couple of
other projects it's just it's just
wonderful to be by his side again and
doing what we do and establishing and
maturing and growing that relationship
is fantastic what is it like bringing dr
strange into the world of spider-man uh
a lot of fun a lot of fun you know i get
to play the grown-ups surrounded by kids
i can say that they're half my age they
are kids i'm blown away by their
professionalism by the atmosphere they
create on set by the fun it is to be on
that set john watts is a phenomenal
director he's such a joy to work with he
really he's great on the granular he
gives you context to understand where
your place is in the story and the
development of it even when all the
story hasn't been finished which is up
in the way with these films at the time
of production starting and it is just
fun from start to finish what goes
through dr strange's mind after saving
worlds and universes a young peter
parker comes up saying hey can you craft
a spell to have people forget
i think the first thing that goes
through his mind is to see in the film
it's like yeah sure i want to help you
out kid you did great back there and uh
you're one of them and us and you know
we're doing we're all on the same team
here so sure help a friend out
it doesn't really take into account that
he's still a kid at high school
and
in trying to people please or going yeah
okay let's do one for the team yeah
some crazy stuff is unleashed and um
and that's where the the relationship
starts to evolve and mature and that's
what i'm really excited about i mean
there's some crazy reveals and fun
spills and thrills in this but also
for me as an actor the thing that
matters most is that emotional
connection to a character and and the
people uh who surround him and the world
that surrounds him so
with tom and i that's that's a really
beautiful relationship that's kicking
off
[Music]
you